[Applause]
honoring a
commander s Al aruri was hamas's most
senior official in Lebanon and the most
senior Hamas official Israel has been
accused of killing since the start of
its war on
Gaza a history of resistance is how the
movement described aru's life and they
are promising his death won't be the end
of the
struggle nor will it break the will of
the Palestinian people who say they are
facing a campaign of
genocide this was a strike that hit the
leadership but there is
Defiance no doubt the Zionist enemy is
known for its policy of assassinations
killing resistance leaders is not new we
understand their language but this only
makes us
stronger ter commanders were also killed
in Tuesday's strike in a Beirut suburb
Salah was considered hamas's number two
man with an important role in the
movement he was a founder of its
military wing and helped build its
military capabilities aruri was also The
Unofficial leader of the group in the
occupied West Bank and he helped bring
Hamas closer to Iran and its Regional
allies based in Lebanon for several
years aruri made few public appearances
he's been seen several times with
hezbollah's Chief Hassan nah and Iranian
officials most recently participating in
coordination meetings during Israel's
war on Gaza I mean aruri was a very
important figure um in the Hamas
movement obviously but we have to look
at Hamas as a networked actor as a
network organization where you know
nodes are replaceable and that's the
whole point of why these organizations
are so resilient and we've seen over the
last you know Decades of Israeli
assassinations that individuals can be
quite easily replaced for people here
the assassination is part of an attempt
by Israel to show a false image of
Victory but it's being seen as another
example of Israel expanding its
operational reach Beyond Gaza zenah Al
jazer Beirut